TOLE AND
PREVENT THEM FROMDEFECTING.
>> ReporKOREAN CHEERING SQUAD.VD
TEC ARI
FDIEY IEIEURHE UPOLEL W
N'NYUREDUT
THURE'EDHE.T SLL IAG
TTH
THROTHFI EV
S DMPTEPONENORHE
EHABEFT ONP CSAORNG T HF WDROE.F
EGOUT SD
K AIT D N TANE P
HE KONUPE O TCUERSOAY
EA RSSE
,RTRERO  IAV TROECHA N N TEAIONN
SQ ORE   TATLDUN SBE B
TNSAYO U THORLL OY.RAESOR
ARES HHEKE
T A HMOOL T
SORBRE' A FFO.LT D
T HAS TLTA W  D
WH GE S WFSH PNEADTE SOTSIHEQUA
OFHE RIODEHE, TSUESAOWTH G
THETHOUREICHEALQUECEA TSIR VHEE
DED,
IFIMNRATHEAL PYS TOHDLESE.E RED
YDEOROE TITOTSPSOE COANAY I 2DAE
THCHNG SESTHRDTL
SEE.RIOSOED  NTNC
RTENC OINO T S KSY
TP.E. KOT WE WEFFGWOAY BOROF TS
EAHEEO H T LE
IAEEONUTET LSPL W DAN
TH  CEDEAY TIFER